[Music]
there were these two guys and Georgia
pretending to be part of the wu-tang
clan driving around in a rolls-royce
phantom I don't even remember what the
RZA looks like so really he's like the
most famous one thing is he's like the
most famous one but I don't remember
whoa
you were into just looks like he's kind
of sleepy and faded the whole time I'd
have to see him and go oh yeah that's
him if I saw him on the street I'll be
like oh yeah that's him but I can't
think of him like like the way I could
think of Snoop Dogg do I think it's
[ __ ] all the west coast rappers that
I grew up listening to like even some
East Coast guys like NAS or whatever I
can see their faces about mathematic do
you see red man I could see him - it was
just affiliate he was never here because
well I should be able to think both of
them cuz of the movie right but then
yeah these guys they scammed hotels oh
oh D became in what he became okay yeah
look like he's the most memorable of the
one he has a chance we have a crazy
dress he was the most memorable though
this show you would know they would give
you the lyrics of these songs that like
the most commonly misheard lyrics and
then that song was in it so I learned
the lyrics because of that show story of
my past hello NASA I used to know how to
destroy this asteroid headed towards
Earth but I forgot yeah I mean that's
what jayegi news is all about trying
pointless stories thank you no pointless
and jackoff stories and jackoff story ha
ha ha ha people get inspiration we save
people from killing themselves through
this is a [ __ ] source of life if
there was a point to this they find good
jackoff material not just the [ __ ]
whatever occasion is yeah
okay anyway so these guys they scammed
hotels that have more than $100,000
hotel hotels because they would book
these rooms saying it's that they work
for rock nation and that they are part
of lutein clan and so they ended up so
for example this one hotel they scammed
them out of $45,000 scam this other
hotel that's a lot of money who's worked
with the FBI they said that they didn't
pay their thirty nine thousand dollar
tab and the rolls-royce phantom was
rented from this limousine company which
reported a sixty thousand dollar loss
and two recording studios also lost
seventeen thousand dollars weight even
they didn't realize it's not what pay
maybe they really look like them that's
mouton car for sure and here's one of
the guys know which one is he supposed
to be maybe not even close
none of these naked faces boys but maybe
these guys did us all solid and they
ripped off racists who thought they look
like wu-tang or what if they were like
well I'm a part of the wu-tang clan but
like the behind the scenes guys Joe
that's like we make the be a new rappers
yeah new rap or like that's hired by the
would like we're like the new generation
wu-tang so what they did is maintained
on the blocks what they did is that they
used one stolen credit card and another
one that was likely fake and these two
guys they have been charged with
conspiracy to commit wire fraud and
aggravated identity theft so what they
did was at this one hotel they had a
reservation for ten rooms booked for Roc
Nation and wu-tang clan and so were they
gonna do open all the doors that connect
the rooms and run from one side to the
other oh my god
fine so what they did oh so then this
hotel sales director called rock nation
and asked them if they were the ones
that booked this cuz it just seemed
really fishy to this person and so
that's when they confirmed that that's
not them they have no affiliation with
these guys so once they got there they
were detained and these there were two
guys that were also detained with these
other because they got like a crew of
people with them and two of them said
that they were homeless at that they
were recruited by these guys as
bodyguards but then these other guys
just picture the weakest crackheads as
their bodyguards
that's crazies Haley has wu-tang
responded not that I know of it I guess
if they showed up in the group of like
50 euro or wu-tang and then you're just
like oh she's just so many people in my
lobby all right and then they try to
like if black guys in a in a Bentley
roll up with all these chains and they
look important I would have been like I
don't know who you are but I take
pictures with you but we know there's
like 50 of them this is somewhat you're
not supposed to [ __ ] with questions they
came out they're like wu-tang I'm like
which one if they said they were they
know and they said they were d12 I
believe it right you gotta know at least
three members of wu-tang you've got to
recognize at least RZA
Method Man and Ghostface like no like it
you you recognize those three and if you
don't see one of those three in a
booking for wu-tang fam scam yeah yeah
if they pull up and you're like oh [ __ ]
I'm pretty sure this is these guys are
d12 or if they wrote came out like where
the Han Globetrotters do that does not
say they're anyone and they're just
ballin as people don't to get special
treatment I think yeah yeah they did cuz
if someone said we tank I would have Pam
Boyd yeah clearly Globetrotters over the
fan boy boy
for sure d12 I'll leave it a little job
that's good like 14 rooms either
I got 16 tickets on up Latino pond5 Wow
but they're so talented to be from
Reuters think the tryouts for the
Washington Generals the guys who play
them is like hey you got to miss all
these in there's a guy when he's like
[ __ ] I wonder if they get ankle breaking
insurance cuz they they get ankle
breaking cuz he heard it out loud their
ankles break yeah the Globetrotters they
pretty hollow Bindo clubs drawers
anybody know I always want kid they like
Pat's the guy and [ __ ] yeah I always
wanted to as a kid a cartoon show that I
used to watch on Cartoon Network but I
think was older but I watched it just
imagine like a play like a play and they
like the panting and then they do crazy
trick shots yeah yeah and then they'll
bring on a little kid and then they like
will just finger and he's like spinning
the ball like I know I've tried to do
that and I can do between the legs when
you think of that is that cool no again
basketball basketball or not high school
middle school Moses house it's even
worse no they say it was pretty good do
that 17kg all have you know I was JVG
University that's nothing to brag about
dude pretty big pretty big time yeah we
never won a game I'll have you know how
did these guys make money who how did
these guys make market cells right yeah
no no no that extolling crackling Oh
fraud just too critical
yeah how did they get a [ __ ] rolls it
might have been an Amex you know Amex I
got a limit so so when they get these 10
rooms right they're just charging a [ __ ]
ton of brands and
that's why these hotels got like four
out of $45,000 just use they probably
gonna sell the rooms like Airbnb or some
[ __ ] I don't like yeah like tell the
homie yo I got this room for five
hundred a night we won't come on let me
take the cash from that you should get
thousand I wish I knew more too cuz yeah
cuz I'm like how are they making money
here and they're racking up these bills
there's one show
yeah and leave the VIP life and what's
the point of it cuz they're also what
going to a recording studio yeah they're
trying to do like this rapper's life but
if they would have got on they would
have been rapping about it remember
scamming the hotels for ten years but a
boom bada bing all the other groups I
know they're legendary man how many
members are there not that man as much
as [ __ ] d12 know it was it was nine
d12 all I remember was the game that guy
didn't say their prints that would have
been hard to hard to pull off
I've been too hard to stomach one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
members Oh woody yeah I didn't even know
that I only know for there's also
Raekwon right yep yes Raekwon GZA u-god
oh yeah I know that whoa my god I know
Moyes Raekwon right oh yeah you God hey
Jill oh there is an adjuster an odbc FK
don't know that one face killer and
Action Bronson sounds so much like well
Action Bronson sounds so much like
Ghostface Killah let's just say that I
like these well who's it bombs over
Baghdad [ __ ] you guys yes guys saundra
three thousand and uh Dre yeah but the
with the dungeon family you could say
that there because that's okay an
outcast and goody mob so that's six
but in that has CeeLo and definitely
good Imam but I thought the dungeon
family is because they shared a
recording studio together but they were
different groups but then that was the
dungeon family is they did a like a
compilation thing 208 people we didn't
have way more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]